et puis vous allez penser à toutes les
tensions que vous pouvez accumuler dans
une journée
se reconnecter à son corps au milieu des
arbres depuis le début du printemps des
balades associées à la sophrologie sont
proposés dans la forêt de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye cette discipline
de relaxation née dans les années 60
visa améliorer son bien-être en
rééquilibrant son corps et son mental
organiser quatre fois par mois c'est
sorti permettent de combiner les
bienfaits apaisants de la nature à cette
pratique psycho corporelle j'ai vraiment
ressenti un besoin de se reconnecter à
soi-même chez les percer les gens on a
quand même vécu des années qui sont
difficiles et il y a un besoin de sortir
de rencontrer du monde
bloquer la respiration est haussez les
épaules
chasser toutes ces tensions du haut des
épaules et soufflaient par la bouche
relâchée
bloquer la respiration décontraction du
visage des trapèzes ou du ventre ces
exercices en groupe vis à se détendre
pour prendre conscience des crispations
éventuelles pendant qu'on marchait j'ai
senti que je respirais pas de façon
régulière donc c'était intéressant de
constater ça et de pouvoir le
rééquilibrer je me suis sentie centrée
aligné dans mon corps
et ça fait du bien qu'on a tendance à
être hyper connecté hyper tout va très
très vite on oublie qu'on a un corps et
qui a qui ne fonctionne pas au même
rythme et à avec la même force que le
mental donc il faut en prendre soin à
prendre à se reconnecter avoir des
moments de calme un travail sur les sens
dans cette balade consciente vu oui et
toucher exalté pour profiter de
l'instant présent dans un environnement
naturel je m'aperçois que on marche en
faire trop attention ou sensation au
bruit au son au contact avec le sol
ça évite d'être trop dans la tête
de redescendre dans les pieds du coup ça
dépend beaucoup en parallèle des
sophrobades adressées aux parents et aux
enfants sont proposés sur le thème des
émotions ou du corps l'occasion
d'apprendre à développer sérénité et
connaissance de soi dès le plus jeune
âge